normalmente es un momento de orgullo en
los antiguos países soviéticos pero este
año el día de la victoria en ucrania
está empañado por la invasión por parte
de rusia los ucranianos ven paralelismos
entre la resistencia contra los nazis
durante la segunda guerra mundial con
los enfrentamientos actuales en su país
debido a los recientes acontecimientos
creo que ahora nadie celebrará el 9 de
mayo tendremos nuestro propio día de la
victoria cuando ucrania y toda la
comunidad mundial ganen a rusia y ese
será nuestro verdadero día de la
victoria y moody's suelen prohibieron
astillas
jeff comenzó a distanciarse de los
aspectos del día de la victoria al
estilo soviético hace más de una década
primero sustituyendo el título preferido
por moscú de la gran guerra patriótica
por el día de la segunda guerra mundial
al igual que rusia el 9 de mayo sigue
siendo una fiesta nacional en ucrania
pero desde 2015 el país celebra los
actos conmemorativos un día antes
acercándose a las convenciones europeas
puesto el 8 de mayo está ahora más cerca
de mí porque quiero estar junto al mundo
civilizado
y ahora acabamos de decidir poner flores
en el día de los guaraníes
aunque los ucranianos intentaron
celebrar el 8 de mayo el día se vio
ensombrecido por la guerra en curso en
la capital y en otras zonas se
suspendieron concentraciones y actos por
el riesgo de bombardeos rusos la
inteligencia ucraniana alegó que moscú
planeaba celebrar parte de su desfile
clave del día de la victoria en la
ciudad asediada de mariupol pero el
viernes el kremlin dijo que no sabía si
sus planes seguirían adelante